[Music]
garry kasparov is regarded as one of the
best chess players of all time his
success within the Soviet Union's chess
team in the 70s and 80s has made him a
household name around the world chess is
hummus in transparent game information
which is available for me at the board
is also available for my opponent and
vice versa it's about making projections
what will happen the chess board five or
ten months from now after retiring from
chess in 2005 mr. Kasparov changed his
game moving into politics he tried to
challenge a new opponent the Russian
President Vladimir Putin people compared
many things such as you can feel just
metaphor for all over the place whether
in politics in 2007 mr. Kasparov
announced he would run against mr. Putin
in the presidential election but he was
not experienced in the game of politics
and it wasn't much of a contest he
failed to secure a place on the
electoral ballot he now lives in exile
in America mr. Putin won that move but
what game is mr. Putin playing with the
West the idea that Putin is a great
chess player is very far from reality
dictators they always like to operate in
secrecy and put as a communicator
secrecy blackmail those are the rules of
his game a game that is far more
consistent with bootys habit
this game of cards poker where you can
start reading your opponents bluffing
and raising stakes
Illinois's in 1999 mr. Putin took over
as Russian president from Boris Yeltsin
as Eastern Europe transitioned from
communism to democracy relations between
Russia and the West improved but after
the Orange Revolution in Ukraine mr.
Putin became increasingly hostile he
felt that America was meddling in
Russia's sphere of influence in 2007 he
used his speech at the Munich Security
Conference to voice his angry criticism
of American foreign policy Parrish
ignores rain eternal Negron et pursue a
web serie of economic if political if
Bowman attorney Spherion na VIU's oh
it's a dirty Ambassador stuff no come
with the Padres America and its allies
kept their pokerface speech was very
aggressive but we welcome the dialogue
and look forward to further discussions
in 2007 Munich Putin made very blatant
statement about his plans to recover the
Russia's influence in the former Soviet
Union it's a watershed moment were is it
different in in language being used by
both sides dictator believes that he
sent a message and the other side thinks
oh it just you know well were being
tested in 2014
mr. Putin embarked on his most
aggressive move yet annexing Crimea and
later invading part of Ukraine in Crimea
Russian troops occupied the streets but
they had no insignia on their uniforms
and there was no acknowledgment from
Russia that it was involved Crimea went
very smoothly all elements of the game
being well prepared Putin didn't care
very much about Western reaction feed em
taste of Kobe here because he really saw
no reaction what do you need his attack
on Republic of Georgia in 2008 mr. Putin
had already tested the West six years
earlier during a five-day war with
Georgia unwilling to confront Russia
directly some Western leaders blamed the
recklessness of jaw
as president at the time in the case of
Russia's war with Ukraine though the
West responded by imposing sanctions on
mr. Putin's inner circle I guess that
these sanctions was kind of a surprise
to him it was definitely more than
Canton expected in 2012 the United
States drew a red line in Syria it told
President Bashar al-assad that if
chemical weapons were used by the regime
America would take military action but
just one year on the regime killed 1400
of its own people with sarin gas America
failed to act and it emboldened mr.
Putin when the UN Security Council met
in 2015 to discuss how to stop the
Syrian regime President Putin was at the
table and was about to call America's
Bluff Assad had to go that was a bomber
said now Putin wants to prove it and a
bomber was wrong or somebody goes to New
York or General Assembly meets Obama
looking in his eye
shaking hands to show in Russian
television that he put it went to
America he tried to improve relations
next day Russian planes bombed
american-backed opposition Syria
in the US presidential election of 2016
the FBI says that Russia used
cyberattacks and social media to
undermine trust in democracy and help
get Donald Trump elected how well first
describing the elections the Institute
of democracy troll factors that were
built in Russia to fight Russian
opposition to create faith needs 13
Russian nationals have been indicted in
America for interfering and damaging the
prospects of the Democratic candidate
Hillary Clinton
so how would Garry Kasparov play against
mr. Putin he says that engagement has
failed
instead he thinks the West must isolate
and deter mr. Putin and his inner circle
through a strategy of economic sanctions
visa limitations and seizure of assets
of course we can call it though of
course we can keep raising stakes but at
the end of the day as long as we keep
being blackmailed in the geopolitical
casino Putin can be viewed as the winner
of the game but it's a temporary game
it's in our hands to make sure that his
tactical games will be turned into the
strategical losses so it's not a game of
cards
but it's the game that I know much
better this is the game of chess and
this is war strategy he's ever seen
you
you